there's nothing more fun than loving
people
loving people is a in perpetuity game of
happiness
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
an actual live interview which is really
exciting to me and we come
strong with an incredible guest with a
new book
and uh someone that uh i don't think
needs much of an introduction but i'm
gonna allow him
to uh say hello and who he is and then
uh and then we're gonna get into the
book and then we're gonna
shoot the [ __ ] about a bunch of things
maybe a little football wine and
definitely a lot of
what the book is about and why and so
matthew it is a pleasure
to introduce you to the show please tell
everybody uh
who you are and and what the book is
about
here we go good to be here with you
garyvee yeah
uh went away to the desert for for um
52 days of solitary finally walked out
of there with a book
that's based on 36 years of diaries i've
been keeping it's called uh it's called
green light
um and it's uh stories
people places prescribes poems prayers
and a whole lot of bumper stickers
um sort of based on 15 years of
chronological
chronological narrative of my life and
it's interspersed sort of with
flashbacks and flash forwards of those
prescribes poems and prayers that come
in and either call back to the story you
just got out of
or propel you into the next story that
you're going into it's ways of seeing
is what it really is that perspective
perspective very much
approach book in a playbook than a
memoir
and the name is it is it does it allude
to
you know going forward like yes culture
like you know because i
you know when i heard the name oh i like
that you know i got a little bit pissed
you know when my jets love affair i
always talk about green i was like [ __ ]
i could have definitely gone with that
kind of friday on yeah
i said don't even get me started but
he's a red light now a chief
um is is that a little bit of like where
you went with it
well so here we go
the the what i ended up with is
believing that every red and yellow
light turns green
eventually in life all right so we love
green lights yes they're far away go yes
a
proceed attaboy we don't like yellows
and reds they slow us down or stop us
but i found out that a lot of the yellow
and reds when is it that we noticed that
you that there's a green light within
the yellow and the red
meaning right now there's no green light
with le'veon bell leaving you
but what is something but i apologize
because you get me fired up
my green light with the jets is actually
my macro professional mission which is
like
okay well this sucks but good news i'm
gonna buy them and when i do i'm going
to win [ __ ] super bowls
so that's my green light within the
river okay
now that one is a marathon versus a
sprint but to your point
i'm definitely picking up what you're
putting down because sometimes i see the
green
and i mean i see the green and the
[ __ ] yellow every time
right the green in a red um is
a little bit more of thinking sometimes
a hour sometimes a year or sometimes a
decade
sometimes on our deathbed sometimes
maybe our great-great-grandkids figure
it out i don't know
some of them but when is it that we
notice
and i think the the tool that i've that
i talk about in the book is
when faced with the inevitable get
relative so one thing is when do you
deem a situation inevitable
yep and then and then the other art is
when
and how do you get relative with that
situation you either persist through it
because you want to get what you want or
you pivot or you hold up the white flag
and go nope i'm fighting another day for
something else
how much is self-esteem a layer
a piece a framework of even making
any of this possible
well i guess you you did i never thought
about it but it has to be a large part
of it to you right because
it's funny right notice where i went
right and i like that you paused and
gave it some feel like
to me i'm listening and i'm already
hyped and i knew this would have plenty
of energy
um i'm just obsessed with self-esteem
because i think i just i just think that
people fall in love with yellow and red
because of insecurity yeah and i think
people
front the green because they're putting
up
fake bravado and ego because of
insecurity and i
and i think a lot about the foundation
of self-esteem allowing to triple green
light in this situation
sure i mean absolutely have that
self-esteem and the ego
if you don't mind me parlaying those two
man of both
how do you have judgment without that
how do you have any identity
um um yeah i mean
self-confidence self-esteem um self-uh
self-reliance uh awareness of self
um i think you gotta have all those to
handle the yellow and the reds and not
again
lay down and wallow in them i love it
over here
because what what everything you just
talked about i was you know
giving you some room because i'm going
to get bombarded for cutting you off
because that's how i roll
so i'm trying to be better evolve in my
older age
all that leads to accountability right
when you talk about all that self work
i'm like right and then that part lays
into accountability and accountability
actually
makes you really [ __ ] happy instead
of the reverse hey
you just i'm i'm sitting down at the
same dinner with you man i mean it's
this idea
part of part of this choice about how to
find
green lights and create green lights
which obviously
we can create green lights tomorrow for
us by our choices today
so this idea that sometimes we say it's
a responsibility and freedom or a
contradiction which they're not there's
a responsibility to freedom and there is
a freedom in
responsibility yes relayed gratification
is what i'm talking i'm a big fan of i
love
teaching about cleaning myself up being
cool to my future self
whether it's the simple thing of putting
the coffee in the damn filter tonight so
tomorrow morning when i'm groggy all i
got to do is push the button
ah nice play makani way to be cool
you know or whether it is how i choose
to be
a husband to my wife or a father to my
children
and how they speak about you behind your
back in 21 years
yeah and you know the end of the end of
let's just dive into this delayed
gratification which i can tell you
you you i'm obsessed big me and man
because i'm obsessed with the journey i
i like the game
way more than the [ __ ] trophy the
trophy doesn't really exist though no
[ __ ]
you know we're just achieving on the way
to unachievable the whole ways well the
way i see it i mean
one of the reasons i bring up the death
of very iconic people
prince i use a lot others is i try to
use that to paint a picture to people of
like
you can have a drillion trophies and
then it's just all over
like you get 24 hours on social media
you get a little hashtag trend
people play their favorite clip they
quote a couple of your favorite things
and literally it's a week later and
everyone's [ __ ] on their life so what
the [ __ ] are you chasing trophy for
don't yeah the result process process
process so
i bring this up i say i i'm a fan of
doing this
a lot too i like to before doing a movie
say sit down with the producers and
directors hey
what's the poster look like yeah yeah i
love it i love it i love what you're
doing right there
for engineering that's right reverse
retention still listen this
let's all ask yourself what's our eulogy
which is going to forever introduce us
after we're gone
well that's inevitable the relative part
is this resume of living we got going
right now which is going to write that
story that's going to introduce us
[ __ ] ever when we're gone
so let me since since it's i mean this
is
talk about sharing the same meal take me
take me to a couple different places
because we'll get back to this
you know so much as me so much makes
sense to me about
my my observations and interactions with
you right now
um now that we've gone to this place
talk to me about
the book from a different way because i
have a we have a big audience on this
and there's a lot of different people
and now i'm going to focus on the people
that are thinking about books
sure did you always want to write one
d is it as simple as you went for this
because i was aware of that little
um you know adventure you took did it
really hit there what would you
like to happen because of it how much
around legacy
and and and you know like what's the
what's the poster like what would you
like to happen like
give me the selfless and selfish
you know altruistic and like personal
makeup absolutely blend of this for you
absolutely
and we'll get into selfish yourself
flesh later on those two are those two
you like that one right yeah i'm about
that yeah i get it
go redefining it to the world that's a
big fan of it so listen i i kept diaries
for 36 years
in my life just because i'm going to
double click because this is fun and we
got a little time
why why did you start day one what
happened well
14 years old probably started it because
you know gretchen donnelly broke up with
me in my
heart i went through my diary like most
people go to a diary
um or journal whatever you want to call
it so i went to a diary for my first
year
when i was lost try to figure [ __ ] out
oh heartbroken damn figure this out why
do i got pimples what's going on
what's this what's this pubic hair
coming in where why won't mine come in
sooner
you know stuff like that so then it
started off with going there to figure
out figure things out and i get my 20s
i got some great relationships going
schools cranking i got a job
i'm rolling catching green lights i
remember saying hey
you better keep writing in your diet
right now while you're succeeding while
you're rolling
my hunch was you're gonna be you're
going to get in a rut again
and you'll you're going to need
something to look back on to get
to recalibrate that i mean enough i
found a rut as we all do
i was able to go back to those diaries
what were your habits when you were
rolling
when you were catching green lights who
are you hanging out with what time you
going to bed where what were you eating
where were you going
um what were your morning rituals oh you
spent a little more time with yourself
before you engaged with the world oh i
got you oh you took that little walk
okay
and i went it got me recalibrated got me
back on the rails and it helped me get
out a certain rut
and find green lights again find my
frequency
again um so i kept those diaries looked
at them all
seven or eight categories came out that
i mentioned earlier from the people
places
prescribes poems prayers uh and a whole
lot of bumper stickers
and then the theme of green light
started to emerge out of those
categories i noticed how i'd engineered
green lights in my life with certain
choices i'd made
i teamed myself up for more saturdays in
my future
giving myself re no more reasons to look
over my proverbial shoulder to see what
i'd left behind
which gave me less stress moving forward
and gave me
more presence and green light um so
dwelling dwelling the elimination of
dwelling
well i i'm fascinated i'm fascinated on
people's inability to understand
that there is no time machine this
notion of i wish
you know it's imperative to learn from
pattern recognition mistakes
strength imperative yes dwelling
looking back and dwelling and and
spending
all of that prevent defense using
football because
that's something i'm desperate to push
on people like it's you
i know i know you you made the wrong
decision
good news right there's absolutely zero
chance you're going to go into a time
machine so
take the learning and just go on [ __ ]
offense and
and eat [ __ ] for another six years to
give yourself a chance to get to that
same [ __ ] road
and this time make the [ __ ] right
call i i'm i think it's all
offense i think every every step is
affirmative even if it's considered
going
back backwards look going back and
looking at third 50 years of my diaries
was an
intimidating idea i said oh i'm going to
be embarrassed i'm going to be shamed
i'm going to feel guilty i'm going to be
you arrogant prick at this time enough i
felt all those things but mostly i ended
up laughing at some of these yeah you
just took the words i was going to say
you i'm curious the first time
you just laughed your ass off well i
mean i stepped i was like
oh my god i looked at stuff i was
ashamed for like oh you kind of already
forgave yourself for that you've moved
on
you know and so a lot of the book is
about me going off into solitude at
times which i think is a good practice
for everyone to do and the reason i
bring that up because it's attached to
the word
dwell but it's it's not and it plays
into this
that example you just said six years go
through and get out of it
every time i go away on my own with my
backpack on my own
the first 12 days are hell i do not like
the company
how many how many times have you done
that
six to eight to ten and are you saying
that the prequels
prerequisite to you doing that is often
the fact that you know you need it and
what you're doing
is reconciling with yourself in that
early part
well i need memory to catch up i'm in a
world where i'm getting too much
frequency i've got no demarcation
between events i'm kind of playing on
autopilot and i'm doing okay
but my head and my heart do not have an
auto bond between them there's a bit of
a dirt road and i got to clean that up
i got to feel my feet on the ground
spiritually maybe i feel a little
um and so i need to go off and i need to
let memory catch up i need to go listen
to myself and find some discernment
into my own judgment what do i want from
me what's going on in the world
what's the reverb here what am i giving
to it what you giving back to me
get some clarity there um happens
you know especially when things are
rolling this is usually coming out of
major green lights
where i need to go away to go is that
green light plugged into a battery or
you have you learned that off those epic
green lights
that if you don't go do that you crash
from the energy
and it puts you into like you're off of
this high it was rolling this was so
delicious
and then in that in between which is
completely always natural for all of us
that the drop-off is it doesn't feel
great so instead of doing that
you're going to go on this offense and
go take that backpack trip and it's
going to make a productive time instead
of kind of coming down from the
project i think yeah well the come down
will be
when you look up and you go oh all the
affluence that you noticed all these
so half the green lights were were
plugged into you know
two volt batteries and they weren't they
were never going to last very long
and it's going away to get rid of the
ones that are plugged into the toy
batteries and going to the ones that go
oh that's solar powered that's so that's
going to burn forever that's burning
after i'm gone
which takes you back yeah yeah
so what i hope comes of the book man i
hope it can help people get find the
freeways i hope
people were gonna i think we were gonna
laugh their ass off some killer stories
i did find out that the stories
did you work with a ghostwriter i work
with a ghostwriter for my books because
i'm very conscious scream and it needs
to be structured for me or
were you able to get there no i went
solo i had to go
right at the beginning stephen cruz he
was from the new york times he had
written a cool article on me i reached
out to him we started
we got together one time new york times
pulled him off the project
which then me and my wife i looked in
the mirror and i was like that's the
best gift i could have been given and
she goes yeah get your ass out of here
take your journals don't go back
so packed up uh steaks and bourbon and
been headed out
and so what i hope man people get out i
think again i think people are gonna see
some killer stories
um i am a pretty good storyteller now
the thing i did learn is that
i thought telling i've performed a lot
of these stories
and i thought if i just transcribed my
best performance to the page that'd be
the best
written word on the page it was not it
needed to be about 30
shorter you got to pick a word out you
don't get the lilt of my voice going up
to you up here comes the punchline you
don't get any of that so
um i think you're gonna people gonna
find some wisdom bombs in here i picked
up a lot along the way
i think i said there's a lot of bumper
stickers what was that to make to make
this fun because i know the process of
book and it's really really fun
who uh any story you can share with us
they haven't shared yet or you have
uh of somebody reading it for the first
time your inner circles the first 15
20 30 people and and anything that like
either collectively they latched on to
and or an interesting observation from
someone that
was fun for you you were like happy your
cousin or your best friend or your wife
yeah yeah anything cool like that in the
first cut well i mean i gotta
get i get i got a call yesterday from
from don phillips and he's a character
in the story he's the casting director i
introduced myself in austin texas in the
summer of 1992
who later on at 3am after we got kicked
out of a bar
and we're smoking a joint on the way
home in a cab he says you ever done any
acting
and i come to this address tomorrow
morning and there's three lines in this
character which ended up being three
weeks work in a film called days
confused
and i moved and it slept on his couch
when i moved out to la
and he's the guy who after about
a month where i'm down to about eight
hundred dollars in my pocket
and i'm telling hey man i need to get an
agent and he snapped at me gave me one
of the best lessons i've ever learned he
goes
this town smells you needy you're
[ __ ] done
he goes what you need to do is get the
hell out of here and go off and
get lost somewhere go to europe go ride
a goddamn motorcycle something but quit
thinking about making it in hollywood
because this place smells you needy
you're done
well he was right that was another that
was one of the guys who actually
a right of passage of a guy pushing me
out of wanting something so bad and he's
right
how to come in needy so i headed off the
leverage you come in
needy you give up the leverage i showed
you hollywood a month later
i'm not even thinking about getting an
agent well now it's time to go get an
agent because i'm like
stories i got i just came from somewhere
man you know
and i uh my hollywood sk like my
knowledge in sports
uncomfortably deep i'm much weaker in
like movie culture and like acting
culture
i obsessed with dazed and confused like
one of my favorite favorite movies and
i'm not even
a big movie guy there were so many so
many of you in that film
i love those coming of age movies to
begin with did that
this just this is probably a very basic
question i'm sure people like booing at
me right now as they're listening to
this
did you get instant acclaim from that
and that was huge leverage
was it a slow burn was it instant like
what happened
like movie comes out you got me in the
door
got you in the door you got me in the
door it got me people curious
got people curious right yeah well it
gave me something for my resume
you know the agent's not gonna take a
meeting with you but it wasn't like you
like it wasn't like
tons of people reaching out and said
okay no no no no no no no no no no no
it wasn't enough i had to find one agent
and
three said no okay even with that more i
thought you were [ __ ] killer
i mean yeah i mean that's staying the
same age line
is like one of the great [ __ ] lines
ever which
i call that a launch pad line that's the
time [ __ ]
working three weeks but now i worked off
of basically because richard lincoln
wrote that line oh is that true that was
the line
that's the line i mean what's that guy
there's an encyclopedia on that guy if
he believes
that he that's what he loves about high
school girls he gets older
that that guy there's a huge very thick
book on him
yes for sure anyway i get a call from
don phillips yesterday
and he's in the book and mind you he's
in the book where i show and how often
can you talk to don
in real life now like it could run hot
and cold like sometimes
every couple of months we check in every
couple of months and we met back in 92.
but he's in the store you know i mean
about i show up at his house
when i'm first pull out to hollywood on
the 26 hour drive from texas
and i show up and he doesn't answer the
door and i keep thinking he shows up the
door with the
with the boner and basically like hey
can you come back later
and i'm like no dude i just drove 26
hours so
there were things in the book and i
called them before them being in the
book i said look i'm going to tell the
truth of our stories
he's like great okay we read the book
and i don't know
he's older sometimes people get older in
the life and they look back and i'm like
i didn't do that don't talk about me
like that well he didn't he loved it he
goes man the book is so humble
it's so true it's uh um and people this
i've had a lot of people tell me this
it's a hollywood am i a celebrity yeah
do i tell stories about
some of hollywood yeah but a lot of
people have told me this one of the
favorite things about the book is what
it is not
i love it i'm not a disher i don't dish
on people i don't tell bedroom stories
and i always say this that's why there's
doors on the bedroom and some of your
business wouldn't be decent
there are people that i that i could
have
named them in the story and would have
would have thrown mud in their face but
i don't have a problem with them that
was who they were we forgiven each other
we moved on i'm not going to i would i
don't i didn't play
stories no names but but you create the
story
have any of those people reached out uh
yes
that's cool yeah they have in in in in a
in a cool
in a cool way yeah um because the more
you know the the the there's people like
i said there's people
there's places everyone's i don't dish i
don't dish on anybody i didn't feel like
that that i didn't what i wanted it to
be when i
when i first went to write the book like
i understand i got some equity as an
actor somebody's going to
buy the book because mcconaughey wrote
it some people won't buy it just because
kanye wrote it either way i remember
saying this
hey can you put go put words on a page
that are worthy of being signed by
anonymous but at the same time be
only only you could have written it
that's that's what word the idea of
where i was where was that how
how has bit i actually have a great
question uh that i'm curious about how
is
promoting a book like doing this show
i've seen some other stuff on social
how is it is it or how is it different
than promoting a movie
how you know any any any tidbit there
that's kind of funny anything you've
kind of picked up on
here's my favorite thing is
this is i wrote this one i directed it i
produced it right
i don't have to prepare look i've gone
out and and i'm honored with what i was
able to put out
i've had i've gone chosen to sell movies
before where
maybe i didn't love the movie and it
wasn't getting a great reaction and i
can tell
if you thought you go yeah interesting
stuff it was cool so anyway mcconaughey
right you've got it you've got to be a
professional
right you know pick out two things that
i'm saying that are that i wrote down
that are my positive
sort of go-to things to say about the
movie but now i don't have to
prepare for any of this
i actually have a fun question the movie
that when you read it
yeah and this might be a tough question
i don't even i again i truly don't have
a good sense of hollywood culture enough
to know if this is a tough question or
not but i'm going to ask it
because i'm just genuinely curious
because i some of the you know as a
businessman
some of the ideas i have in my head to
then see how i
executed it i'm like wow this sucks and
i control a lot of that as an actor you
don't
literally you thought everything was
going to be epic and then it just didn't
post well you know like the
post-production you're like [ __ ]
really what would be yeah what movie
were you most
hyped about and then you were like [ __ ]
man that didn't go and then in reverse
what movie what movie were you and by
the way it might be uh
something you thought was gonna be an a
plus plus plus plus and was a b minor
i'm not talking a
and f yeah yeah yeah yeah and then in
reverse what movie were like
you most like you were most and whether
it was your age
what's the reverse so yeah which one did
you come in the hottest
and we're like and which one were you
coming in with the most like i don't
know and like holy [ __ ]
well all right let me answer this
all right i could say this man for for
the second half
dallas buyers club is a movie we made
for 4.9 million dollars in 25 days
yeah remember the movie that almost like
never got made and we wheeled that into
existence by now asking permission that
movie and that movie
again i claim i don't know a lot but for
some because it was such an epic one and
you were
[ __ ] insane and it was so epic that
movie
was bouncing around as a story for a
while right yeah i had
i was attached to it for about five six
years before but no one would make it
with me
no one wanted to make it i'm making it
again my lack of knowledge just putting
up the money to do it
you're gonna pay for the money period
period peace age drama with mcconaughey
in the lead no no he's a rom-com
shirtless guy that doesn't make any
sense no way right right right
right because you were coming off of
that yeah yeah you were in that place
yeah
and by the way as an actor is that
important like are you sitting there
and saying [ __ ] like if if i don't show
some other side i'm rom-com to the end
well check this out and it's it you'll
see when you when you check out this
part of the book and it's part of those
affirmative ways to not too well but to
go into appendage to get out the other
side
i look up and notice i'm rom-com
romantic comedy guy and i'm owning this
because i'm like you damn right those
rom-coms are paying for the house that
i'm renting on the beach that i'm going
shirtless on
guilt you know so but i did notice
well i want to do some other things no
no no no you can't do that and i noticed
i was like oh the industry and the
public are
nothing other than rom-com shirtless cat
on the beach
that's when i went okay well if i can't
do what i want to do
i got to quit doing what i've been doing
that's right and i went off back down to
texas
and hid out and called my agent money
people and everybody said i'm not doing
those anymore
20 months nothing nowhere 30 months
20 months and are and are peeps getting
antsy around you like hey [ __ ]
do one
right no i called it early on i mean i
called i believe i
dropped dropped tears to make the
decision because i was like i even
thought about i was going to change
careers
now mind you this at that time this is
when hollywood really got the message
about six months into that sabbatical
saying i'm not doing those
an offer comes in for equipped at 8
million bucks i said no thank you
they come back 10 million i say no thank
you they come back at 12.5 million
uh they come back at 14.5 million
i say let me read that script again
i read the script gaby guess what now it
was the exact same words
as the original offer but i read that
script again and it was better written
it was
it's worth it
and you did it but i said no you said no
said no what's that wait real quick for
fun i love this [ __ ]
was that movie made no no
did not make it they did not make it hey
by the way on that note
one of my other favorite things about
hollywood that i don't know the story is
the way i know sports
anything that you passed on that went on
to slay
and the actor [ __ ] crushed any of the
you have any of those in your
i got there i was off a roll in la
confidential
i don't remember if it was the uh
i don't remember the co-roll or the guy
roll but i love that movie and that was
a really good one that was awesome
climbing was it money was that you
weren't in for like what what enough
happened it was right around the time
when a time to kill was coming out so
all of a sudden
i go from a weekend i go from a friday
before time to kill comes out which is
the movie that came out that sort of i
was the lead in
it was a big studio film the friday
before that comes out
i'm wanting to do any 100 of these
scripts you're offering but you're
telling me
holly was telling me 99 times no one of
them you can do
well monday 60 something hours later
it inverted 99 out of these hundreds you
can do
yes and so it was it was that it was not
whoa
wait a minute uh what am i supposed to
do with all these yeses how do i get
some discernment discrimination in these
yeses i don't i don't know
three days ago i would have done any of
these now you're telling me i can do all
of them
i need more than 24 hours in a day and
they're not giving it uh so i said
i passed because i just wasn't sure i
wasn't sure a lot of
stuff that at that time um
so yeah movie here's the thing with me
on movies i haven't
i've never done or been a part of a
piece of art that actually
met my expectations
do you think you ideologically decided
it will never happen
because of the way the machine works
like i i
kind of weirdly understand what you just
said which is why i'm going to where i'm
going with this question
do you believe that's because if you
were
observant enough to understand the macro
and thus
immediately deemed it will never happen
no i i think i think we may be saying
the same thing what i'm saying is
earlier when i said there's no such
thing as a trophy
i think i i don't ever i've done look
some things have
been different and better than i thought
they would be but
nothing has ever been nor as any
performance i've ever done going ah
perfection now what about what about you
what about you watching someone else
you know in the in the cocoon of the
industry because i'm sure
your relationship with the industry ebbs
and flows it's like me with wine
but in it in it and when you were really
observing
did you ever watch a performance to say
and said
my jesus [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] was
that sure yeah yeah i mean i mean but
really really really because there's
those incredible performances i know
that but like
from your perspective because it's
subjective curious what
hit your radar is like [ __ ]
yeah um you know let me just
say this i like making movies more than
i like watching them
um and i haven't even seen all the ones
i've been in
and it's not because of any i just i
just we were talking earlier
uh about that gap between what we want
to do and what we actually get done all
right there's a gap
between what i want to do what we do in
a raw performance and what's actually
getting recorded on the camera
then there's a gap between what's
recorded in the camera and what's good
and then there's a gap between his
editing what's in the final picture
that's right
die back like what's different about the
book door
what the example i just said is four
filters away from the raw expression
where is this this is one filter away
because it's just
it's a written word you and i right now
is the filterless
stand-up comedy is the filter list i
love it so much that's why even the way
i give keynotes has
nuances of it because it's the most
[ __ ] unfiltered that's it
that's the nectar that's the really
straight one-on-one without a filter
translation
have you ever cried when your favorite
sports team lost the game
for real no what's
the most pain you ever felt in a loss
in sports the most pain i've ever felt
in the loss um
well you're thinking i'm gonna buy you a
few seconds i cried
multiple times and like like six to 12
times a year in sports up until
22 years old and then just stopped i
cried when garrison hurst
broke off a 98-yard run against
jetson overtime in 1998
in week one of the nfl season
and i think and that was the last time
by the way and i i wonder if
if i realized somewhere in that moment
that i'm 23 years old
it's week one it's week one
oh my god you must be
oh man it's real rough right now but
honestly i you know it's funny
this might really strike you i'm a huge
sports fan they
the rangers in 94 and in the new york
rangers in 94 and the yankees of 96
became my first two championships you
know i started in 82 with all four teams
and literally literally the second they
both won their championships
i basically have not watched a single
game like i've watched a little bit here
and i've never watched i don't
i think i've watched a complete game of
either team since their champion
whole journey all journey heard which
which is why that [ __ ] you know it's one
thing to be like
kind of passive after a championship
most people double down after a
championship yeah yeah
i'm completely like and i don't say with
a badge of honor i'm just
fascinated by how real that is to me
well
what's more you know i think i
understand what you're talking about i
mean which one the
the trophy the championship is the noun
it's static
it's got a period at the end of it the
ver the the the
the getting to it is the verb oh it's
the ba by link
you know what's the one why do you think
why do you think i like the jets so much
it's so
fun to be this year you may have i'm the
happiest
you've got good job security with
enjoying this jet ship
talk to me about wine a little bit i
know that you know we've through the
years have talked about that like
where are you in that journey like you
like it you don't
obviously bourbon you talk a lot about
you love that like where do you where do
you sit with wine
if anybody um red guy
i'm intermediate yeah i've been
introduced i've got friends that know a
whole lot more about wine than i do that
turned me on too
and you like a lot of others enjoy that
six guy
10 people together like that wine night
is like a fun night for you like
yeah yeah and and like i said i like to
you know i'm also
a fan of uh a little bourbon and some
tequila as well
um but no come on
in a finals match bourbon versus tequila
is it bourbon wins or tequila when
i don't know that one that's a good one
i like that you know you go back that
other question you had to go
2010 university of texas national
championship game against alabama
yes our quarterback gets dinged uh on
the goal line
early in the like the opening drive and
he's out
we get beat we didn't have our starting
quarterback for the rest of the game
what would have happened
that was a that was a what if hurt
ah you know so what about ut basketball
you
have you ever historically gotten
hardcore about that or has it only been
football getting more hardcore
because yeah because i'm because i i'm
getting to be
uh uh friends with our coach smart i've
gotten to know some of the young men on
the team
and you're starting to get in more and
we're building an arena which i'm which
i'm uh um
part of your culture and over there the
new arena where the men and women are
gonna play basketball
i love that what about um startup
culture i know that you know a lot of my
friends
in startup culture have nice
relationships with you the silicon
valley the app culture like where do you
sit with technology
um i'm leaning and learning into it more
now than
i ever was before friends of art guy oh
siri
introducing me to things and and and
learning a new vernacular is what i
meant
you know um there are a lot of startups
in austin that i'm
some of them i'm reaching out to that i
like their product
and they're in austin and we could have
some part and parcel
uh uh uh partnership in between
in between the two of us in a business
that i'm starting there in austin with
the minister of culture work
um so i'm learning more about it
um you're flirting more in that arena
i'm definitely flirting more
and understanding it it's it's a new
video and if i asked you entrepreneurial
spirit
where do you sit today at 50 were you a
lemonade stand kid did you hustle that
way
was it more art and storytelling has it
grown like we're not i'm more
entrepreneur now than i ever was
at at 50. and it's it's part to go back
to another word you mentioned earth it's
legacy choices now
so what are the choices that i can on
that i can create like this minister of
culture is a category that i actually i
assumed and created
um a lot of people think it's political
i'm like no no it's in the slipstream
it's it's it's about values and it's
bipartisan and non-denominational and it
can still also
be a business um so
at 50 i'm going what choices can i make
that i can hand off to my kids and they
can hand off to their kids
that's going to be my shadow that goes
on um
you know and i don't know if i'll do
i'll do more movies but movies are
capsulized
they're little pieces of time i'm trying
to challenge myself to go hey the big
show is life
it's live uh the recorders always but
but it's awesome that you like
that you're i think a lot of i watch a
lot of people
in all arenas just kind of completely
walk away from
a thing that was the major stepping
stone
i've always liked the idea of like you
know i'll go back to movies you know to
me like
i started a wine brand last year i sold
it recently but like i always kind of
knew even though i really needed to walk
away from wine because it was all i did
that that i would come back to it but at
that time
you know called 2011 to 2019 i just
didn't want to
as much and like you know and and even
now i'm like and i will again in 17
years or
you know like i think i think i think
people close doors
that are there that is usually their
first step almost
out of ideology or out of not realizing
that
yeah cool you're burnt out now but don't
put a final nail in the coffin
you don't have any clue where you might
be in a decade mentally about that thing
right well so like you just you sold
your wine you were into it it was it was
it was a
little obsession you told it was that
like the
your your yankees win the championship
that you put it away or do you have it
sitting over there
actually that one's a little sweeter i
started it only 18 months ago so this is
the winery not my dad's wine store which
he still owns and operates
my family business i started a winery 18
months ago that
that one has a much more warm feeling in
my soul i had two partners in that
business
nate schroeder and john troutman they
started as interns for me a decade ago
okay so the the story yeah yeah yeah
yeah
of like it just like the the thought
that the
collateral of my skill set could put
these two young men
who i adore like younger brothers in a
position that
changes the course of their lives at
least financially
uh which is only a piece of it but a
piece of it
was too romantic to say no when the
opportunity came yeah yeah yeah yeah
that drove me that drove me remarkably
in a very serious way that's what drove
that decision
well so that door is always open that
that there's no final trophy on that
because those two young men you're gonna
you're gonna enjoy watching where they
go and how they do it even more fun back
to leadership and coaching
i've got a thousand employees right now
that i have at least 60 of my
people in that ecosystem of like wanting
to rep so yeah that that there's
nothing more fun than loving people
right
loving people is a in perpetuity game of
happiness like
you know i i often make jokes about not
lighting liking animals
because hey i probably skew under most
people with like dogs and other things
but it's i really believe it's because
of my love affair with
humans like walking down the street i
have a warmth
towards people and i really recognize
that most people don't go there
let's lean into this to where we are
right now and where we're heading
all right i got asked this the other day
where do you lie on trust
okay hey and i'm like they hadn't
thought about it uh
and the person asked me and i said look
i go into
i'm talking to you right now you have
a hundred percent of my trust until you
don't
same you everything i don't think
enough of us are looking at the world
that way right now i need your distrust
and major disbelief can you come in with
a hero
until you earn it i hate that [ __ ] 100
i read that [ __ ] i hate that where the
[ __ ] are you
why are you so [ __ ] audacious who the
[ __ ] made you special enough
that another human has to earn it [ __ ]
you
where's your humility i'm 100 trust as a
matter of fact
i fight a lot of time i'm i need to work
on myself
to try like when trust is broken i'm
still
trying to come up with empathetic
scenarios for the other person
i would be very bad at baseball i think
i'm seven strikes and you're out like
one three strikes don't even [ __ ]
register for me
and that's something now what that's
done is also created a subconscious
resentment
that i've had to become as i continue to
go through my process i'm like oh right
i think that it's seven strikes and
you're out but what's happening is
with each strike there's a little bit of
like you know fluid going into that
bucket of
resentment i might be able to eat it
because i'm strong and i don't care
but i'm building it so i have to be more
thoughtful of having cancerous
conversations
with people i care about so i don't get
there yeah
that's my tweak i i i hear you i don't i
can't allow seven strikes but
i hear you that's a resilience you're
gonna know i can handle it i can handle
it i can handle it
i really believe if someone does scar me
um
and on the on the role of forgiveness
and moving on
man if i see real a real sense of
retribution and on their end wanting to
go hey i bogeyed
i screwed up i'm sorry i'm very quick
quicker than i forgive myself brother i
love you for that and that
leads to foundational happiness it just
does
real quick because i know you have to
run i'm curious you
and social media do you use anything do
you have any
burner accounts that say mcconaughey is
actually awesome like
how do you how do you roll with social
like what's wrong
in i started i i started uh instagram uh
i think about a year ago okay and you
know i've been flirting with the idea
four years
okay downs with me is i was going like
ah the rabbit hole of that conversation
i've got three kids man i got a family
it's like they're you know they offer me
they're always coming come on play
fantasy football i'm like i don't need
another hobby
i got i and i want to do it and the
whole instagram thing was like i'm
afraid i'm going to like it a lot and
i'm going to do it too much so i came
out and i remember my opening i said
look
it's going to be a monologue guys yes
it's a one-way street
well i don't i don't go i don't i don't
want to dive into late night looking at
a a comment on every single thing i said
because
i'll feel it um and i want to engage in
it and get that conversation so i'm
choosing about where i have the
conversation
nice work dustin um do you find yourself
following
certain people or certain accounts and
getting a little bit of like
escapism value from it uh
a little bit or is it mainly i'm i'm in
the mood to say
something uh and i'm gonna just say it
and it's a monologue and i'm out
it's mainly i'm in the mood to share
something hey this is a pulse i'm
feeling
uh out there in the world right now this
is a pulse i'm feeling in
in america or something that's going on
in my life like share this
i will then re-engage with certain
people that i will
follow or listen to um and check in with
but
but but i don't have it i'm not ready to
have that nor do i know if i ever will
be to have that on my proverbial
good morning now let me go sit down with
my ig world
because like i said i got three kids and
a wife and a job and i like my own
solitude and i'd rather i'd rather as i
can live here as i can
october 20th yep that's the date
it's a date green lights and that's the
idea man let's how can we create more of
them for ourselves and
others as you said be selfish and
selfless at the same time those are not
contradictions we can make the choices
that are best for the
eye that are also best for the wii
the second you get best for the eye your
ability to be a champion of we
exponentially grows boom
and where did where are we misinformed
on that i don't know where along the way
people missing for a lot of things
there's so many listen this is why
communication
videos books monologues or somebody like
me that posts that
spends eight hours engaging like this is
why we need all different versions one
sentence in that book
can change the way someone looks at it
vaynernation
i know that uh i have a lot of pride in
this i i
a lot of my friends are just people that
have randomly emailed me
uh the book pr community very much knows
this has been a show that
is a substantial driver and it's because
you're curious
and i think uh if you if you re-list in
the first ten minutes
clearly if you're getting value out of
me it's i have some serious confidence
that you're going to get value out of
this book
so green lights october 20th make sure
you pick it up
makani thank you so [ __ ] much for
being on the show
i enjoyed it gary look for the next time
bud can't wait take care of yourself
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out